when I die I hope whatever happens next
is even half as beautiful as Abzu it's
mesmerizing soundtrack and Wind Waker s
visuals are among the most enrapturing
in recent memory yet the game's true
beauty stems not from it's bittersweet
score and inviting undersea environments
but from its unfailing ability to imbue
every moment with childlike wonder Abdo
is serene and meditative calming and
cathartic moving and timeless it's
simple components assembled so elegantly
as to become something altogether richer
there's a striking sort of purity about
Abzu that invites comparison to another
equally powerful game journey like
journey abscess characters are nameless
it's story wordless its campaign brief
it also issues many of the mechanics we
might consider standard for a modern
adventure game including combat
character progression and fail States it
even lacks the ambient multiplayer that
made journey such a profound experience
for many players but Abzu finds meeting
in other places and like journey evokes
a vast array of emotions with grace and
ease
the campaign follows a linear path
you're typically free to explore areas
at your own pace following subtle
environmental cues towards hidden
details or grasping onto massive
creatures like orcas and manta rays as
they glide effortlessly through the
blazing blue water you can even pause to
meditate at certain statues allowing you
to experience the world from the
perspective of the animals around you
doing so doesn't earn you anything it's
simply an opportunity to observe and
enjoy the thriving ecosystems layered
into every environment from lush kelp
forests to pink coral reefs to murky
black trenches Abzu captures the
otherworldly beauty of the ocean and
populates each breathtaking backdrop
with its own unique fauna you'll find
all manner of fish sharks eels whales
crustaceans and more all of which behave
believably and yet somehow I never felt
threatened
curious awestruck even intimidated but
never threatened there's something
profoundly peaceful about drifting
through that world with no heads-up
display or score or objectives to break
the spell
that is not to say however that Abzu
abandons gameplay completely in fact the
swimming itself feels surprisingly
satisfying thanks in part to the games
novel control scheme you swim straight
ahead by simply squeezing the right
trigger leaving you to look around with
the right joystick and change direction
with the left regardless of how you
twist in maneuver your character fluidly
adapts to your every input meanwhile
tapping X with the proper rhythm builds
up your boost allowing you to flick
gracefully through obstacles and breach
into the air if you speed towards the
surface silly as that may sound it's
actually pretty exhilarating
especially when you can entice the
school of fish to swim alongside you or
get dolphins to flip and squeak almost
as if they're playing with you
ABS is also more than a simple ocean
life simulator as you push forward
you'll encounter several light
exploration puzzles and even a few tense
moments of action but more importantly
you'll begin to dive deeper and deeper
into the game's unspoken narrative
you'll uncover some strange yet adorable
robots almost immediately and start to
notice scattered ruins of an ancient
civilization shortly thereafter the
further you progress the more exquisite
the ruins grow with gilded paintings
intricate tile work and ornate Moroccan
windows hinting it's some tragic past
later areas and gameplay evolutions
though simple proved remarkably
affecting within the context of the
experience cleverly subverting
expectations established by the game's
earlier portions of course Abzu isn't
perfect the camera occasionally clips
through larger objects for example and
the mechanics walk a very fine line
between minimalist and just straight-up
simplistic but these shortcomings are
utterly inconsequential in the face of
absolutes countless artistic triumphs
like the music the soundtrack shifts
dynamically as you progress through the
environments stitching together various
compositions on-the-fly to create a mood
that matches your surroundings without
explicitly calling attention to itself
and that's not all at certain moments
the camera slowly pulls back to
communicate the overwhelming scale of
certain creatures and environments I
swam I to I with a blue whale and have
never felt more awestruck or
insignificant in a video game
on another occasion I emerged from a
tight cavern and was suddenly enveloped
by a vast empty chasm with an endless
darkness beneath me
again the deft camerawork turned in
already memorable moment into something
truly incredible art exists to bridge a
gap to communicate emotions or ideas
that would otherwise be impossible to
articulate absolute does this
courageously confidently sincerely it's
stirring soundtrack vivid colors subtle
storytelling living world and thoughtful
execution combined to create a
singularly moving transcendent
experience in a word Abzu is beautiful
you